Jennifer Anderson is in the morning show
premieres November 1st exclusively on
Apple plus it's hard for me to believe
when I watched the first two episodes
that this is not based on what happened
to Matt Lauer on The Today Show because
and by the way it's fascinating because
it's about a guy who's one of the
biggest Morningstar guys and he [ __ ] up
and he gets thrown out bury me - uh-huh
that's Matt Lauer and this guy Carell
people he is the archetype for those
unfortunately many men who work there
was more than just Matt well yeah I mean
Charlie Rose Charlie Rose right but
Carell looks like Matt Lauer a bit
doesn't he there is an uncanny it really
is that's why people are gonna say that
but it's not yeah and Reese Witherspoon
how do you team up with her well we have
elenberg that comes came in and said he
had bought the rights to this book it
comes to Reese and myself would you like
to join in on this we both said hell yes
can't wait where do we sign and was it
fun doing this he it was fun and
extremely challenging all at the same
time an apple did they a bit now
fabulous they are fabulous you recommend
other actors go work 100% they're
wonderful they're incredible partners
they're very supportive they stay out of
your way they let in which I think is
the is why these streaming services are
people can go and and make you know
create films and television that they
are not able to do now in the studios
from you know for whatever reason they
have much more free rein and I think
it's just so much more creative freedom
and fulfillment
you can watch Jennifer Aniston in the
morning show premiering November 1st
exclusively on Apple Plus which is
really very exciting that's actually you
said